[Music]
you mind if I tag into the journaling
conversation yes do you Journal I do I I
say this in the special you you just
played a cliff but I I find if you write
down every few nights what you're
saddest about or angriest about you can
start to see your own life as a story
and when you see your own life as a
story sometimes you can zoom out and
encourage the main character to make
better decisions
wow I I find I was love how you just
worded that also it's probably great
material for you all your sadus stuff
it's honestly like it's it's it's the
basis of like so much of the old man in
the pool is like finding the humor in
the things that are the hardest yeah
because I feel like that's sort of like
I don't know I think that's the coping
mechanism of Comedy yeah which is a it's
a good coping mechanism it's not bad yes
so um I I heard that you didn't
initially want kids right in life I
didn't either initially yeah I was
reluctance my I wrote my last special
was called the new one and uh is all
about how I never want to have a child
and all the reasons why and how I had a
child and how I was right uh and and
then ultimately how I was wrong and
that's why it's emotional and you know
this these shows I always try to I've
done about five of these solo shows and
yeah that's me and my daughter at the
old man in the pool oh that's so cool
that was Lincoln Center now I know I
know then you pop them out and you're
like wait a minute you're fantastic no
she's completely the best but I I always
was like you know the first I would say
like the first year was really hard and
that's when I wrote that show it was
just like this period where I was like
like I felt as the dad like I was like
nothing you know like I was the intern
of the family like I was I was this
pudgy milkless vice president of the
family huge title no power also overseas
Congress and I was just like this is so
hard and then but now she's she's eight
and she's the just the greatest and like
it's I mean it's amazing you're going to
have another special about when she's a
teenager oh yeah no I mean I my brain
goes to when she's 16 because she's
eight now but my brain goes to when
she's 16 and she's going to be like my
dad is garbage you know what I mean and
and it'll happen like that's natural
that's that's what development is but
like my you know my dad didn't have to
deal with that like it was the 80s no
one listened to children like like we
said it but he was like is someone
talking you know what I mean and that's
how I ended up being a comedian but the
uh childhood trauma yeah for the wind
but like when she's 16 she'll be like my
dad is garbage I'm going to be like
she's so right ah how can I amplify her
voice she's so brave know I
me how can I ampy
she's the great I mean she I'm so lucky
she's the greatest you are so funny oh
you've covered so many areas already
okay so wait your your Broadway show
you're talking about the old man in the
pool and now you made the jump to
Netflix that's you were so successful
that they you now are on Netflix that's
amazing netlix yeah it's uh I'm so
excited for two reasons one is that it
you know the show is about death and
mortality and I set out like four years
ago to write the show that all
essentially like jokes and stories about
life and death and losing people and how
hard that is and how can we make people
laugh from that like can I do that and
so I had this fear when I did it like oh
no like what if this is really hard for
people to hear who are going through
losing people and all that stuff and
actually it was the opposite it was this
thing where people would come up to me
after shows and be like I just you know
lost my dad I lost someone in my family
recently and that's what I needed to
hear right now like I needed to laugh it
was hard for me to laugh for a long time
yeah so that was cool and then the other
side of it is like and I was going to
ask you folks this is um we I talk about
this in the show we weren't in I love
you family growing up like we don't say
I love you like in our family we say
take care which is not the same which is
kind of like which is kind of like what
the person says at the grocery store
like can you see them the next time take
care it's a very grocery store bank
teller kind of thing yeah uh and it's
it's kind of a passive aggressive
command like
yeah like I'm going to need you to do
something for me take care you know what
I mean and did you were you I love you
families uh we were and I mean and we
are oh that's sweet I mean I I say it
many many times to my kids a day it's a
little Annoying I do to my daughter sure
I'm saying I'm saying with my folks yeah
they they they were they were little
yeah you know the the thing was yeah
like it was it was weird because I you
know I'd be dodging you know I'd be
dodging smacks across the head one
moment and then and then I'd love you
would come as do you yeah and then
you're like a little and then you're
like you for the next 20 years you work
on what the definition of Love is yeah
plausible deniability after that that's
incredible that's any kid in the
South let's do another commercial break
Mike's latest standup special is called
the old man in the pool you can see it
on Netflix starting November
21st
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home